i was all wrong about what confidence
meant i thought confidence was a
personality trait
you can't transfer to me that which
you're not experiencing yourself
you have to physically be experiencing
it in the moment it can't just be the
words you're reading from a sheet
you have to really believe it stop
making excuses
stop telling yourself little watered
down assessments
of where you're really at tell yourself
the truth
wanna be happy live a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you have
michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the five skills
that you need to build a multi-million
dollar business
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with skill number
one build confidence with mel robbins
when you talk about personality so
extroverts introverts
a lot of us really i know i did this i
was all wrong about what confidence
meant
i thought confidence was a personality
trait i love this
tell me more i thought that people that
are outgoing are the confident ones
right and the truth is
confidence is not a personality trait at
all it's a skill
and a lot of the extroverted people that
you know are actually very insecure
i used to be one of them i used to be
the kind of bossy crass
loudmouth that didn't believe in myself
that didn't believe in my ideas that
didn't have the
confidence and the courage to really be
the real me who i am who i'm not flaws
and all
there are tremendous number of
introverted people
that feel uncomfortable putting the
attention on themselves but they're very
very confident in their ideas they
definitely believe in themselves
and so when you start to separate
confidence not as
a matter of personality but as a skill
that you can acquire because confidence
is the ability to move in my opinion
from
thought to action because when you're a
confident person
you believe enough in yourself and your
capabilities
that you're willing to try that you're
willing to share
to me confidence isn't the assuredness
that it turns out
it's the willingness to try and and
that was a huge insight for me skill
number two
is master the skill of communication
with ed mylett
the best leaders say old things to new
people
they say the same things over and over
again to more and more new people new
teammates new employees new recruits new
clients
new speeches new groups right they say
old things to new people they're
repeating over and over the vision and
the cause of their business of their
movement
these are great communicators the next
thing all great communicators understand
whether it's words
physiology the look you give somebody or
writing
influence is energy it's the transfer of
energy it's getting you to
feel about my company feel about my
mission feel about my product
feel about my cause what i feel they're
conscious of transferring energy to
people
because that's what moves people that's
what gets them to act it's not just the
words it's not just your face it's not
just how you're dressed
it's an energy transfer there's a hook
by the way
you can't transfer to me that which
you're not experiencing yourself
you have to physically be experiencing
it in the moment it can't just be the
words you're reading from a sheet
you have to really believe it i love the
book by my brother evan carmichael built
to serve you guys this is the kind of
thing you get in this book
most people wake up and drive to a job
they hate think about your five closest
friends
are they happy do they live their lives
with purpose do you
we put on a fake front for what we want
people to see and think about us
but the reality is most people aren't
happy we're lost we settle
you can't be happy if you don't know
your purpose and then he goes on to
explain how to do that
you guys should get this book built to
serve by my dear friend evan carmichael
skill number three is master the ability
to close
with dan lok the number one skill that
you must
master to be rich is closing skill
the ability to close not just people
skill the ability to connect
and make people like you i'm talking
about the ability
to influence persuade and convince
other people to take the action that you
want them to take
that's closing i want you to think about
this everything and anything that you
want
in your life that you don't have right
now other people
already have them resources capital
context fulfillment success whatever it
is that you want
other people already have them what you
need to do is develop the ability to
close them to pursue and influence them
to give that to you
see wealth is not created wealth is
transferred
i'll say that again wealth is not
created wealth is
transferred so how do you do that i want
you to think about elon musk
elon musk is a closer when he does
a presentation when he does the new
announcement of tesla
guess what he is closing there are many
forms of closing you can close
one-on-one like this
you can close one too many where it's
one to one hundred
one to two hundred one to one thousand
you're closing on camera
you're closing on the phone it's all
closing you look at steve jobs
when we remember when he announced the
iphone
guess what he was doing he was closing
he is a closer right richard branson he
is a closer
bill gates he is a closer all these
people one buffett
he is a closer if you've ever seen his
annual shareholder meetings guess what
he was doing
what he always does is closing
he is selling you on the vision of the
company
he's reporting to you what he's done in
the past
when you are an entrepreneur guess what
that's what you do
nothing happens until a sale is made in
business
so guess what you're out there you are
selling your vendors
why they should give you better terms
you are selling
your employees how they could perform
better you're selling them on the vision
where you want to go
where you want to take them to guess
what when you are talking to customers
you are selling them
why they should buy from you and not buy
from somebody else not buy from your
competitors
you're selling all the time the question
is
are you a good closer that's the problem
with most people they
are not good closers they have this
negative association towards selling
towards closing like it's like a dirty
word oh i don't i don't want to sell
people
you're broke you don't want to sell
you're broke
as an entrepreneur let me give you a
definition
it's not the only definition but it's
the best definition that i've come
across
an entrepreneur is a person with a
vision who orchestrates other people's
time
talents money and resources to make his
or her vision a reality
notice every single one of those things
you got to sell
other people you got to close other
people
to give that to you skill number four
start telling the truth with
jocko willing we lie to ourselves
we don't tell ourselves the way things
really are and when we do that
then we can't fix our problems if we
can't fix our problems we're not going
to improve
so we have to be truthful to ourselves
i have to be truthful to myself you have
to be truthful to yourself
you have to stop rationalizing stop
making excuses
stop telling yourself little watered
down assessments
of where you're really at tell yourself
the truth
so that you can get where you want to go
you can be who you want to be you can be
who you should be
you should be when you do what you know
you should do
when you pay attention to the little
things when you implement
discipline true and unflinching and
unmitigated discipline in your life
when you stop when you stop trying to
find a sweatless
solution when you look for weaknesses to
work on
when you allow no easy excuses
and all that starts when you stop lying
to yourself
when you stop lying to yourself that's
when you can become
who you know you should be when you tell
yourself the truth
about where you are so you can make sure
you are
in the right place and if you're not in
the right place that you can get
yourself on the path to get there
the path of discipline the path of hard
work
and the path of
truth and skill number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is build a network with grant cardone do
you believe that what you know
or who you know is more important and
why yeah i believe that i've had this
conversation with a lot of people i
believe who you know is more important
than what you know
why is that well you you know look your
connections man the connections can
accelerate everything so uh we did a we
did a growth conference
uh we did my annual growth conference we
did one there was 9 000 people there 23
speakers
you know i didn't know this years ago i
was out there
competing i write about this and if
you're not first or last
the competition thing is a dead art you
don't you don't want to compete with
people you want to collaborate with
people
and i didn't know this because the way i
grew up because my dad died probably i
didn't have any connections
and because i didn't have connections
and i didn't have a network and i wasn't
in the club
and i wasn't in the country club and i
wasn't at the golf course and i didn't
have didn't know the bankers
i probably because i didn't have those
things and i didn't know how to do it i
probably made
networking like wrong as opposed to
using it to collaborate
right because i can tell you a whole
bunch of people that are less talented
than me
that that went faster than me
and so that that's exactly my whole
point of this entire show
and if you listen to this all the time
you definitely know this is this is
where i stand on it
but what you just said it basically
encapsulates my entire purpose for this
because i feel like
the what is obviously important you have
to be competent you have to have a skill
set and you have to work on that
craft yeah yeah but i just find that if
you if you focus more of your time on
the who
the speed will always be greater like
you'll skip rungs on the ladder you'll
shorten the runway however you want to
phrase it you'll
get so much better so much faster and if
you combine the two
you're unstoppable if you are committed
to greatness
and you collaborate with other people
and and lift them up
like make other people great yeah you
know my sister said to me when we were
doing this conference it was four days
she's like my god you shared you this
the amount of time you give other people
on the stage is unbelievable
right we did a four day event 9 000 plus
people
that was incredible and you know i give
speakers
that why why grant well you could be up
there the whole time i said no i'm
sharing i'm sharing that platform right
right now what does that do for me first
of all it edifies me
for sure it's like 100 i don't need to
be on the stage
they're on the stage on my behalf um
it gives me a network a built-in network
so we spent four million dollars with
the mandalay bay
yeah so it was incredible to give me an
instant
okay i got i got speakers that came from
around the world
to deliver content um
i didn't pay them i spent i wrote a
check to mandalay bay for 4 million
bucks i gave them an audience
they can't most people cannot put 9 000
people in front of themselves
so i did that for a whole bunch of
people and gave them a great qualified
audience so
you want to do whatever you have to do
to do what you're saying which is build
this network
like to reach up and and i i realized
one day i was watching
cnbc one morning and i saw all the
players on the planet
the top 50 or 100 players or whatever
that number is
they were all um showing up in davos
in switzerland okay buffett gates
all the players the the google boys i'm
like dude this
look what are you doing grant what are
you doing man
you're so stupid dude you need to go to
davos you need to show up where the
other players are you need to go there
and eat dinner
eat dinner with the kings and the queens
now i know some people this goes back to
this
last thing you said about the the
morality thing yeah
i don't need all that okay when you say
you don't eat all that you're being
selfish
you need to eat with kings and queens
and power players
because it's gonna accelerate everything
for your family right like if you're one
of those people that want your
greenpeace guy
the best thing you could do is go eat
dinner with bill gates
right rather than being in your little
freaking zodiac boat
just just just doing the zodiac boat
thing attacking the big ship
you need money you need funding you need
support you need people behind you you
can't do anything by yourself
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you
going to do to take action on it this
week when you write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan and when you share your plan
and have public accountability it raises
your chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan to take action on it
this week let me know put it down in the
comments below
you don't have to be an extrovert to
sell you also don't have to be a slime
ball to sell either
all you need to sell is a vision that
you believe in
and a passion to make it come true and
if you don't learn to effectively sell
that
genius idea that you have in here that
can serve the world
will never come to fruition and you'll
never get the impact that you're after
so i'm here in la and over the past two
days i've been on the podcast for jordan
belfort
wolf of wall street and jay abraham
who's the legendary
marketing guru for tony robbins and
damon john and a whole bunch of other
people
and i'm on their podcast i'm telling
them that they need to be on youtube
that they need to get their message out
i want to see them more heavily invested
i want to see their message reach the
world
and five years ago
evan or five years ago would have been
too afraid
to humbled to worry that i might not be
perfect
that i wouldn't be able to persuade them
to do the thing and so i wouldn't have
tried
and i still have a bit of that in me
when when jordan belford asked me
how good are you like how good at
youtube are you
and the answer that i gave was within
the thought leadership world
if you you want to help entrepreneurs
i'm i'm top three five in the world
even as i said it feels weird saying it
because the the canadian
or carmichael kind of humbleness is
pumping in
but it's also true because when you're
talking to somebody
who is not super familiar with what
you're doing they're trying to get an
understanding when i'm talking to jordan
belfort
and trying to give him an understanding
of what i do and why my message is so
important for him i'm trying to serve
him i'm trying to help him i want him to
win
so the credibility is important backs it
up and me not
strongly believing in myself means that
he won't believe in me either and one of
my favorite messages from jordan and i
told them
this at the beginning of the podcast
interview was sales
is about a transfer of certainty of all
the things i've learned from jordan
belford that is the number one thing
that still rings true in my head sales
if you want to sell people you want to
persuade them on something
it's again not for nefarious reasons not
to screw somebody over not just to get
their money
you want to persuade them i'm here
trying to persuade jordan
trying to persuade jay try to persuade
lots of other people
to take their message and put it up on
youtube to spread it to the world
it's for them right i got frustrated
with jordan halfway through the
interview
and he said why are you frustrated
because he's making it a joke and some
and having fun and he loves having fun
on the show and
and it's a more entertaining show he's
way more funny and entertaining than i
am
i told him you're doing this for the
audience because people watch the show
i'm doing this for you like we're here
at a limited time and i want you to win
i want to get this
out of my head into yours you can go
take action on it
right so the ability to sell and
persuade
is based off your ability to transfer
certainty
and so when you fully believe in the
thing
when you fully believe in the thing like
this is right this is the thing that has
to happen
in service in service for your customer
in service for your audience you have to
do this
not for me but because it's the best
thing for you when you fully believe it
then you have to go all in on it
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check the link right
here below me or if you want to learn
the five universal skills that will make
you rich
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe
and i'll see you there